there's no recycling this answer because
if you just say it's possible there's a
general impeachment inquiry out there
it's not news and they're recycling this
impeachment narrative what because they
don't want to cover pedophile Island
whatever you just don't talk about
pedophile Island so context when we talk
about impeachment a little bit here yeah
a lot of folks have not that many
honestly but some people have asked why
we don't cover the impeachment I guess
we would say proceedings just the whole
impeachment I worry more sometimes
people say like is it is it you've seen
these comments because you don't want or
anything critical or a new boy Trump my
boy yeah boy yeah boy you eyes what are
you the the guy in charge the people in
the railroad tracks and Cool Hand Luke
now listen here boy to communicate the
impeachment proceedings it goes through
yourself so here's why let me explain
why here really quickly in a hop I don't
know if you have a longshot Harper keeps
pacing back if he does he does not where
there's a dissing PT basis the
impeachment is [ __ ]
there's nothing new this is the truth
there's nothing new to report we did a
whole segment on impeachment a while
back
nothing new has happened and it's it's
remarkable because usually September
October November we've talked about this
half-asian but these are the fast times
for the news right that's your news
cycle and then it sort of breaks between
Thanksgiving and Christmas which should
tell you that news is manipulated if all
of a sudden two Americans nothing really
happens but for some reason September
October and this far in November they
have not there's there's nothing going
on and so they're kind of slowing down
their own news cycle by continually
covering impeachment and I want to be
clear this is a long montage because I
want there to be no doubt the media has
been claiming really for years at this
point but certainly the last few months
the last several quarters in Oriya had
record economic growth so you can see
that he is and I don't just wanted to I
know I saw MRC did a great montage of
them talking to the media talking about
impeachment but what I want to
specifically address is they've been
saying that
for over a year that removal from office
is imminent right and that's why people
the story catches up all this time he's
going to be impeached if you don't
believe me don't take my word for it
automat Tuesday the walls closing in on
president Donald Trump the walls are
closing in it feels as if we're getting
closer and closer to the truth it must
feel as if this is closing in on him
folks Donald Trump is clearly losing it
feels like the walls are closing in
[Music]
impeachment is happening and they are
going to impeach him I mean that's the
think that's a foregone conclusion at
some point in the future Donald Trump
will no longer be President of the
United States this isn't a fool what is
well we know that it's complete Jason
Priestley is a proof devastating to
Donald Trump and he will not survive it
the only out that the president will
have the only eldest is how to resign
the office when that day will come I
think it'll probably happen before
Christmas you're slightly after it looks
like some could be impeached sometime
around the holidays Charles will you
believe that actually president Trump
will what resign or be forced out in the
next 12 months yes I do actually thing
ding-ding-ding we got a winner now with
the market crash if Trump were impeached
no the President cannot pardon himself
to avoid impeachment stop the hammering
in order to save his family and himself
I resign part of the children by Mike
Pence very much like Richard Nixon was
the president cannot pardon the vice
president to avoid impeachment in 2014
Donald Trump tweeted is he crying are
you allowed to impeach a president for
gross incompetence he's not give the
president any
well I guess we're about to find out
the tiptoeing is over the whispers are
turning into shouts is now the top story
in the country Donald Trump in the
country he's done there's no question
he's done off the two years of avoiding
its Trump may finally face articles of
impeachment from its coding us to
impeach him one of the organizations
that launched the extreme piece which
from last year that's what this moment
needs from reporters is more reporting
on a day not more speculating or
guessing what he's asking for real
reporters do you work by yourself of
what's going on I'm gonna fight another
budget it was also working the President
of the United States is actually a valid
topic watching President Trump you have
the sense of someone looks like in a Jim
Hansen character that stayed in the
creature shop gets to see this ending
now does it end at the ballot box in
here does he make it to a second term
does he reside I said it weeks ago I'm
going to say it again mr. Trump will not
serve out his term residents no way no
how
he will be forced to ultimately resign
this week Tony Schwartz a very your Kato
circle is closed they never been
recommending something that Trump is
going to resign and declare victory
before Muller and Congress leave him no
choice Trump's presidency is effectively
over would be amazed if he survives to
the end of the year more likely resigns
by fall if not sooner
does it cover back up that is liberal
catnip them can't tell they start
printing the bestseller list now but
it's someone that is number one right
now we win okay so it's like catnip for
[ __ ] hack clones
it is just I wanted you I always want to
put timestamps on it was going to take
too much work thank you so much to our
our P Gibby who put it on of course
Reggie's like here's this is so
important that there they're saying it's
imminent this is really want to be clear
about this interesting well could he be
impeached like george w bush they wanted
to impeach right they have consistently
been if you watch CNN for 24 hours and
I'm never doing at 16-under
live-streaming I'm not no please not
broke me mentally I would rather be
waterboarded by Tim Kennedy all day a
day I heard I heard all day
two hours or days per day which means
absolutely serious in case because you
will see when you watch CNN for 24 any
24-hour cycle breaking there's like uh
engagement is imminent yeah and of
course if you watch The Young Turks you
get eye cancer so and the reason by the
recycling this Americans if you just say
it's possible there's a general
impeachment inquiry out there it's not
news right you don't need to break your
news cycle for that that's why they
consistently have to claim their oh it's
going down today it's happening it's
like a school fight today by crack three
o'clock here we go and they're recycling
this impeachment narrative what because
they don't want to cover pedophile
island that was see an amy robach go
back to our interview with James O'Keefe
pin Jeffrey Epstein
known pedophile yet a pedophile Island
was a sex ring trafficker a leader of a
sex he was a sex trafficker who had a
ring I don't know it's a sex trafficking
ring that seems appropriate right yeah
the point is anything the media can do
whatever they can do just don't talk
about pedophile Island can we try not
Erin Brockovich to talk about tap water
or some be some chromium somewhere it's
not a beach mess if it's not an there's
only something else well there's really
isn't them because do you want let me
prove this nothing meaningful nothing
meaningful and data cleaning
case-in-point brian Stelter literally to
hit in tight and I'm not saying
literally like Millennials do like
figuratively because you're going to see
literally did an entire segment when you
wouldn't talk about impeachment brian
Stelter this week when I'm doing
impeachment an entire segment counting
president Trump's typos I've never seen
anyone do a comprehensive study of his
spelling errors for a reason
fact base is this excellent website that
has every single word the president says
some other politicians as well it looks
at all of Trump's tweets even the
deleted ones for this database of typos
and other screw-ups okay he could have
introduced that segment literally saying
I've never seen anybody else waste this
much of your time yeah hard-hitting news
anyone do an entire segment on Trump's
tweets which by the way I'm pretty sure
they have it's like I've never seen
anyone do an entire segment on the
African squirrels not gathering patterns
in relation to climate change so we're
gonna do a special a two hours hours
marathon Stelter I mean Stay Puft we've
done the segment but I just I don't get
it like there are people I disagree with
that I understand like Anderson Cooper I
don't agree with him but I get it he's a
good newscaster Chris Cuomo I can't
stand but he has the right connections
at least he's got a face for television
like I kind of get it if you tuned into
whatever API even some women on the view
you understand that they can kind of do
the cackling back and forth there's some
kind of value there
Brian's out there he's a he's a
talentless formerly gap-toothed bald fat
that seems really gay gets every single
story wrong it's like a Rubik's Cube
that I can never figure out like I want
to bring in a Japanese kid to tell me
how to do it
homonym I don't know maybe that's the
brilliance of brian Stelter
he makes us seem to have such little if
any redeeming qualities as a human being
that the only criticism of him can be ad
hominem and he can play victim maybe
that's a strategy D chess man these
people they will they will cover
anything on Trump if it's negative even
if it's not newsworthy and I just don't
see the purpose of covering something
until it's relevant here and I want to
be clear about this like when there's a
terrorist attack we always best practice
as we try to wait or if there's a
shooting wait for a little bit of
information because we're not really
beholden to having the exclusive scoop
on because this is an entertainment show
we don't want to get people wrong you
for me you don't want to be wrong
information not only are they proven
wrong verifiably over and over on
Trump's impeachment their own
narrative keeps changing right so first
it was he was going to be impeached
because of the Russian collusion a
mullah report found nothing yeah an
incredibly extensive investigation
turning up every stone right and found
them so they're like well then we got to
find something else I gotta find
something else because they have to do
real reporting guys and everybody slept
with my wife was the one who told me I
have to die and we already said the
Muller report was gonna end him so I
would like sweetheart who I think is
beautiful and have sex all the time what
should I cover and she was like
impeachment okay I wish I loved anything
as much as he loved faking being
straight so then after Russian collusion
it was he being Donald Trump would be
impeached because of the Ukrainian quid
pro quo called their bluff President
Trump didn't release a transcript turned
out to be nothing baller so then the
Democrats so they don't want the
whistleblowers to appear right they
don't wanna I'm actually up here they
she wanted to be anonymous but they
continue to contradict the official
transcript and they say that there was
some funny business going on of course
no identities are being released as far
as whistleblowers and they're not
testifying with the Democrat and I
understand we'll get into whistleblower
laws and protecting anonymous sources
but with the Democrats and to me it's
always an anonymous source that has all
the info that's the concern you should
just pepper it in every now and then
with something verifiable and here's
something else the - I do want to talk
about go to bill here really quickly
because Rand Paul talked about this you
know the right to face your accuser
right now that's an in a criminal case
right in this case it's not a criminal
trial but they are making criminal
accusations so how does that is so
that's one context - that is important
that articles impeachment aren't limited
to just crimes they there's just a
general kind of bad acts umbrella that
could be used for articles of
impeachment which is this you know
relatively new and gray area about where
you're going to be able to answer the
questions but I think the most important
part would be why do we have in the
criminal system the right to face your
accuser it's because when faced with the
harsh reality and light and that's
strict questioning people's stories will
either stick if they're true or they
won't right and here that is the point
if there is a whistleblower the
whistleblower has allegations the
allegations are true then
whistleblowers should have certainly
there will be consequences I'm sure but
there should be that ability to allow
the highest office in the land to be
able to address those accusations I
don't understand the world how much to
let understand that there is some great
territory with this law and that's why I
wanted to get your taken but what I
don't understand is the world of the
left lives in where someone can come
forward completely anonymous with no
evidence at this point and something
that contract evidence or whatever
claims that contradict their previous
claims never face the music never
appeared but we don't know who they are
and the press the president gets
impeached like I understand the game
that they want to play you think he's
going to be influenced do I think the
articles will come yeah they will
yeah and I think I think they will
because of the showmanship that needs to
go into it as opposed to a legitimate
basis right because there's remember
it's it's we say this all the time
anyone can file a lawsuit for any reason
it's it's the next question because
there's no gatekeeper saying at the
courthouse that's well let me read this
first and decide if we're gonna let it
in similarly even though there are
procedures in place that will require
them to jump no kind of Hoops to jump
through to be able to have the articles
of impeachment again and again and again
we keep hearing the cry wolf is it is it
is it two years ago that he was getting
impeached immediately how about at 18
months ago no 12 months ago six months I
mean at some point you just say look if
you've got it show it yeah
at some point yeah at some point it
would make their case a little strong
make it easier for them and it would
also make it easier for me so I would
wouldn't have to read your stupid
questions about why I'm not covering
impeachment anymore now if the articles
are brought forward if there's an
impeachment absolutely we recover you
but at this point just filling out what
he's gonna be impeached now no no no no
no no no
when is then now soon free crab tomorrow
in in in here's something else too that
I haven't heard anyone else talk about
this it doesn't mean that it's
necessarily original but with all the
recent recent impeachment hysteria right
now it's been about the Ukraine
yeah has anyone stopped to consider the
massive contradiction first it was going
to be impeachment because of Russian
collusion and that didn't work and now
it's the Ukraine and by the way
Ukrainian officials I don't know if it's
the president Prime Minister several
afib high rep officials have said that
Donald Trump did not pressure them right
right the Democrats say that they're
lying and they're just trying to make
Trump look good I don't know
know this but Ukraine and Russia are
mortal enemies they don't like each
other at all this is pretty recent right
30:14 was Russia that the annex with
with the Crimea I don't watch Russia
today because I'm not a Putin puppet
sorry but ever since then the relations
between Ukraine and Russia have been
extremely tense as of right now by the
way they have no diplomatic relations
Ukrainians have officially recommended
its citizens don't even travel to Russia
at all and they've even banned some
Russian television stations and by the
way though the Kremlin warned I mean it
looks like they've been sending in
troops to aid the pro-russian rebels and
their efforts 10,000 people have died so
far in the conflict so if Donald Trump
was really Putin stood which they're
still claiming by the way the Renia why
would you cranium presidents or prime
ministers carry the water for Trump if
he is a plant for Russia they would have
every incentive to expose in damage
Donald Trump as much as possible because
they hate Putin right ain't no Russia
it's like the moon landing conspiracy
the pointy hoppers upset because I was
talking about brian Stelter and he saw
the clip the moon landing situation
the reason i let alone a second if the
moon landing was faked we believe that
all world governments are internet
together the russians who wanted to get
to the moon first would have every
incentive to release to the public that
the United States faked the moon landing
because they'd want to embarrass us
right the same thing with the U with
Ukraine I guess you don't say that
anymore they drop this up with Ukraine
they would encourage every reason in the
world to try and hang Donald Trump out
to dry if he was a Putin puppet and by
here's something that's not debatable
okay we have to go to Donald Trump jr.
in a second
but this is something that is not up for
debate and I rarely say that it's not
like like Samantha bee or Young Turks or
Chelsea I know realism but the fact is
not up for debate in this case I will
say it I will put my stamp on it if you
believe the mainstream media and you
really really hate President Trump you
have you still have to pick either
president Trump is a puppet for Putin or
he's working quid pro quo with his
buddies in Ukraine it has to be one or
the other yeah period but the media and
the Democratic National Committee they
want to impeach him for both what does
tell you about the legitimacy of these
claims hey there you were subscribed to
the channel hit the notification bell if
you're already subscribed to this
channel because that lets you know when
new videos come out and they don't show
up on the youtube search feed also there
are videos playing in boxes here click
one of those just of all the things that
I just mentioned all you have to do is
one and if you don't I will run for the
United States presidency under the one
one thousand sixty four percent Cherokee
Party I have yet to pick my VP